MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So in this lecture, you want
to look at hadron colliders
very briefly as an introductory
lecture to this topic,
but also as the conclusion of
the discussion we had in QCD.
So historically speaking,
hadron colliders
might have been
the tool in order
to probe the energy frontier.
So, and that has to do with
accelerator technology,
the fact that heavy particles
emit less synchrotron radiation
allows them in
circular colliders
to be collided at
higher energies.
This plot here shows
as a function of year
the energy of the constituents.
So these are the
elementary particles
used in the interaction, or the
energy of the quarks and gluons
being part of the interaction.
And you see that
typically we find
that hadron colliders,
here in red,
have an edge over lepton
colliders in terms
of the maximum collision energy.
So the energy
frontier usually is
given by the hadron
collider as compared
to the lepton colliders.
The protocol is a
Livingston plot,
and it's a little bit old.
We are now here in 2020.
We haven't built
this machine yet.
We might build a lepton collider
at 250 GB in 10 years from now
or 15 years from now.
And also, the LHC is very
stable at this energy here.
But the point of
this lecture is more
to discuss how we can make
a cross-section calculation
of important photon collisions.
So we have already
seen how we can
make this cross-section
calculation where we have,
let's say, an initial quark
and an anti-quark colliding
with exchange of a photon.
We haven't seen how we can
do this with a Z boson.
But we'll see that next week.
This process is called
Drell-Yan production.
And we're looking at the decay
either of the photon--virtual,
so virtual photon, or the Z
boson and a pair of leptons,
electrons, and muons at highest.
So we can calculate this.
And we call this cross-section
the hard scattering
cross-section--
the cross-section
of this hard scattering process.
But we need to, in
order to calculate this,
know the momentum
distribution and the abundance
of the initial quarks
and anti-quarks.
And so we do this
using the structure
from the parton
distribution functions,
as we discussed them before.
We have to integrate.
And those are labeled
here with those q's.
We have to integrate them
over all possible momentum.
And we have to
sum over the quark
species inside the proton.
For this process, we don't
have to consider the gluon.
Because of leading order, we
cannot produce a lepton pair
with gluons.
Higher orders, we also have
to consider gluon densities
in this discussion.
And then the momentum
of the parton collision
has to be equal
to the momentum--
the center of mass
energy considered
in the parton cross-section.
This process, this technique,
here is called factorization.
So we factorize the
hard shattering process
from the structure
of the proton in
the cross-section calculation.